إساءه ارتكبها كاتين جديده لي
الأخلاق lunel law واقع قبلي لا لكن
أفكر في 4 لقطات الويبرنوم و
أشجار الأنسولين الفكاهة تطير إليها
فكرة حشو سبتمبر بادالونا
إشارة إلى
هاجم ميشيل الصباح
قد تجد مينا واتارا شريف إدريس
مقام على كل حال يستحق مهمته
في
المملكة المتحدة هؤلاء الأثرياء المحترمون الجميلون
تصلب أو الجانب bir el ater ل
إدارة الأب وسويوز جميعهم يبلغون العاشرة من العمر
هل يصنع مكواري أو حمص
باتاكلان بن وودسايد عجلات المورمون
إلى دانيال بسيني إلى سيرافين جديد
العالم al farra cydia لكن لم تصفية
على أربع جزر الكاريبي ماساجويل
باتاكلان تعرف إلى أوساكا ليلى فستانك و
اهتمامات محمود عزت بعيون فريد
وجه و
بنيت الشعار على عجل للعودة إليه
المصدر لكن دانيال
[موسيقى]
ماذا يعتقدون
تمريراتنا الستة ل
[موسيقى]
قبل بضع سنوات في رحلة صعب
في القدس تخليدا لذكرى والدي
وأجدادي
أتذكر تلك البلدة القديمة
يستحم في ضوء بري جميل
[موسيقى]
من بلفيدير كان بإمكاني رؤية جدار
رثاء وساحة المساجد
هذا مفترق طرق للأديان مثل
أخبر في الدليل
دون أن أصدق ذلك كثيرًا لقد ضحيت لـ
عرف لم أكن أعرف ماذا أكتب
قليلا عن طريق الاستفزاز أنا
أدخل رقم هاتفي
إذا كان الله موجودا فسوف يناديني بما فيه الكفاية
ثم أضع قطعة صغيرة من الورق فيها
الشقوق في الجدار من الواضح أنني
لم أتلق مكالمة من من
إما
[موسيقى]
في 13 نوفمبر 2015 كنت على حد سواء
مراقبو الانقاذ الضحايا بعد ذلك
بأعجوبة
وأحب أن أصدق تلك الليلة
ربما كان يفكر بي
[موسيقى]
نعم
نحن
أوه
أعوام
أو
دعونا ننتهي بعد ظهر الاختبار لدينا
مضيفة الآن سيدي دانيال
psenny مساء الخير سيدي
كنت صحفيًا في العالم الذي كنت عليه
ضحية نفسك في الهجمات الإرهابية
13 نوفمبر 2015 في باتاكلان
وإذا كنت أنت الذي صور بالمناسبة
هروب المتفرجين من باتاكلان
كنت مصورًا لفترة طويلة
لقد حصلت على بطاقتي الصحفية منذ عام 1977
الآن ابنة الصحفي الفخري
على رأي القول
مررت بأفضل فترة بدون
نأسف ولا ندم كان عظيماً لدينا
تصنع أفضل الصحف وفي الصباح
حرر العالم بالطبع
أعتقد أنه كان من الجيد بالنسبة لي التصوير
الصفحة
لذا دعها تذهب مع هذا الحدث
مأساوي للغاية ولكن على أي حال
هناك توافق الأزمنة والذي قال لي
دفعت إلى كل هذا
[موسيقى]
13 نوفمبر و 2015 إنها مصادفة
أدخل القصة بالصدفة
[موسيقى]
13 9 سنوات كان علي العودة إلى المنزل
من الراديو للاستماع إلى حفلة موسيقية
موسيقى فيلم لأنني أحب
الكثير من ذلك
وبعد ذلك لأسباب x استسلمت و
لذلك عرفت كيفية العودة إلى العمل هنا
بقية حتى يجعلني أكرر يوم الجمعة
سارة زوجتي لم تكن هناك أرض
يتحول في بودابست وحدها في باريس
وصنعوا هذا الفيلم مع جان هووز
anglade كنت أرغب في رؤيته
إنها قصة رجال شرطة تائبين
ولذا نظرت إليه منذ فترة حداد
سلام
ثم جيد في 9:40 سمعت مثل
طلقات الالعاب النارية
سماع هذه الأصوات اعتقدت ذلك
كان في الفيلم
بعد فترة سمعت أن ملف
لم تعد الطلقات كثيرة
بصوت أعلى مما لو كان في فيلم وانسحبت
كثير 1 ثم إنه انفجار
[موسيقى]
ثم أدركت أنه كان يحدث
بل في الشارع أنت على الشاشة
ذهبت لفتح النافذة ل
يفحص
هذا هو المكان الذي قرأت فيه ما سمعته
طلقات ثم الناس الذين
كانوا يفرون
كانوا يصرخون في وجهي قلت لنفسي إنه كذلك
شيء كبير يحدث
وبالنتيجة فإن الجريدة تشرح لي ذلك
الصور
في البداية أعتقد أنه أ
تصفية الحسابات في المعركة في
أرباع ولكن من أخرج مسدسًا
يبدأ في جذب فقط أمام توماس
من الواضح أنهم يفرون من الذعر
رؤية أن هذا هو ، أنا أدعو
مذكراتي هو في الواقع كان لدي أن
بنوا هوبكوين رقم واحد من
محرري الدنيا وقالوا له
استمع انه يومض صنع في المنزل هو
يحدث شيء خطير للغاية
الدرس
وهذا هو المكان الذي يوجد فيه أودي بالفعل
عدة حوادث إطلاق نار في باريس
فيلم البندقية
[تصفيق]
ماذا يحدث
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نورت
[موسيقى]
ما أراه فظيع هو أنا
أنا لم أر قط أنه ملف
لقد رأيت يا أخي أن الأمر متطرف
عندما تفهم أنها خطيرة جدًا
لديك هذا الوهم بالحماية
من خلف الشاشة وتشعر به
محمي
[يضحك]
في مرحلة ما أنا عند النافذة و
لا شيء يحدث بعد الآن
أرى الناس متوترين أمام
باب باتاكلان للهواتف التي
بالتأكيد شرارات من الجرحى
حاول الاتصال أو مات بسبب
التي أخرجوا هواتفهم بها
لا ارادي ولكن هناك المزيد من الطلقات هناك
لا مزيد من الصراخ
[موسيقى]
على الرغم من أنني لا أعرف ما الذي يحدث
داخل
هناك مقاومة هناك بشكل غير مباشر
هناك رجال أرى أنهم قتلوا
لذلك أغلق هذه النافذة
من الصعب أن لائق
آخذ شاحن الهاتف
أرتدي حذائي الذي أرتديه
أنا في قميص
تذهب إلى نهاية خطوتك ولكن
من لا يعتقد أن هذا هو من سيساعد
الناس الذين هم في أسوأ الأوقات
المواقف إما أنها تؤلم dargaud
نيساند
يبدو واضحا بالنسبة لي
هو بحذر
أعزف على العمود أتكئ قليلاً
beaurevoir givet بحذر لا
ذهب أفضل هناك هو نفسه هناك
لا شيء قليل صمت رهيب
معظم الجثث أمام
باب باتاكلان وهناك فقط
شخص الذي قميص أحمر وقال م في
ما يقرب من عشرة أمتار على
تطويق
ذهبت إلى هناك بحذر شديد وبالتالي أنا
انحنى عليه ورأى أنه
كان حيا
وكذلك مع شخص آخر موجود في
عزيزي الشارع هذا لأنهم سيكونون
هناك ويتحقق لأن هناك من أجل
يتم كتابة ضربة توأم في منتصف الشارع
حتى مع ذلك سيتعين عليهم جذبه من أجل
وضعها في القاعة حتى لا يكون
يتعرض في حال قيام السيدة سار بإطلاق النار و
الرجل الأسود يختفي ولذا أطلق النار
ماثيو أكثر من ذلك بقليل على متر ل
لتتمكن من إغلاق هذا الباب
مثل أسافينه التي أدعوها Benoît
اشرح له ما يحدث
لدي تحت عيني وعشرات الجثث
أخيرًا الأشخاص الذين فروا من خلال المساهمة
بالعشرات أو المئات ولكن هناك
هوامش
لديه حرق كبير وداعا نعم
الهاتف يقع على الأرض في القاعة
لا أعرف لماذا أفقدهم
الأحذية وأنا أتفهم أن و
يزيل الرصاص وبول الدم
أنا على علم ولكن ما زلت أحب
أننا أخذنا لكمة
سوف يهز شيء ما إذا كانوا يعيشون
أنا أسقط أنا ميت
إذا بقيت مستيقظًا فمن أنا
على قيد الحياة
[موسيقى]
كان بينوا بريت هو من أخبرني بذلك
انتظرت ستفعل قبل سبع دقائق
ألتقط الهاتف من أجله
أقول إنني كنت على قيد الحياة
لكن هذه اللحظة تنقذ بشرتك
لقد نزفت جيدا هناك أنا لست ذرتي
أخذ رصاصة سيكون من الضروري الصعود إليه
المستشفى وكيف
من هذا القبيل إذن إنه عملاقه
لهم قميصي وأنا صنعت نفسي واحدًا
عاصبة
أنت تفعل ما تدفع بأسنانك
من ناحية أخرى جيدة أخيرًا du
من الواضح أنه جيد أنا
قيل لي أنني سأتصل بجاري
برونو وستيلس الذي يعيش في الرابع
ليأتي ويساعدني
[موسيقى]
نحن
وعدنا بأننا سنكون
غادر قبل عيد الميلاد
أنت فقط تريد أن تنفق شيئًا ما
كل شيء في windhoek لا يتحول إليه
اسم انها حقا الكثير من المتاعب هو
أخبرني أنه لا يستطيع تحمل المزيد من هذا
مرور نعتقد أنه حتى اليوم
عندما نعود يفضل تجنب ذلك
يرى أشياء لا أراها
لم أر أي وفيات صحفية ولم أشاهد
الصور التي سوف تهيمن بالصدمة
أكثر ما يطاردني هو الرجل
الذي يدير الجزء الخلفي من رأسه أن
يغلق
في الأسابيع القليلة الأولى لكل منهما
مرات مررت في شارع فوكو
شرق
لم أخبر أحدا هنا
وأعتقد أن هذا ما أردته
اسمع هذا ما كنت أبحث عنه
الانتقال إلى الخارج
أوه
سوف تنسى ذلك العمدة لكنها في طور العملية
ليمر من الصدمة يتنهد
[موسيقى]
[يضحك]
في يوم الجمعة هذا الثالث عشر كنت قد حددت يومي
لقضاء بعض الوقت مع كليمنت
كان هناك مخرج 10 في الصيف في المتحف
بيكاسو نفس الصباح
[موسيقى]
كانت لابنتنا الكبرى في الصف
الطبخ مع المدرسة لذلك كان عليها
العودة يوم السبت
شاهدت المباراة على شاشة التلفزيون هناك
كانت المباراة على ملعب فرنسا كلها
أتذكر
[تصفيق]
الى
و ال
انفجار خلال مباراة كرة قدم
أخيرًا الانفجار
توقعت الازدهار وبعد ذلك سمعنا حتى
المعلقين الذين يقاطعون و
من يتساءل أيضًا عما يجري
نفس المشكلة
فكرت في منتج
سلام أنطونيو كان لديه رجال
واصل لعب فرنسا
في وقت سمعناه في الشارع
ضوضاء بدت كضوضاء
آلات ثقب الصخور
وبعد ذلك بسرعة كبيرة خلفنا سمعنا
صراخ الناس يصرخون
لذلك هرعنا إلى النافذة نحن
شاهدت ما كان يحدث
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
أفكر على الفور في الإخوة
كواسي شارلي عبدو وأنا أقول لنفسي ذلك
هذا هو
وتشارلي عبدو هذه الشوارع الثلاثة
بعيد
نحن نفهم أنه هجوم
بالنسبة لي مثل مشهد سينمائي
ركض الناس الهبوط
تحت الشظية
لدي طفلي الذي ينام وهو يعلم
كان في الواقع يبلغ من العمر خمس سنوات في ذلك الوقت
استطيع ان ترى ذلك
[موسيقى]
بالنسبة لي للاتصال بمركز الشرطة
من يجيبني ، سيدتي ، لا يمكننا إخبارك
مساعدة وهكذا هناك جاستن رجل منذ
طلقات خلال bataclan malin هناك
طلقات في كل مكان في باريس وهناك
إطلاق النار على باتاكلان في باتاكلان أنت
على البخار حيث أعيش فوق أنا
انظر هناك الناس يركضون
في الشارع وهناك أسمعه يقول ذلك
أطلق النار على باتاكلان لذا أغلقت المكالمة
في الواقع يقولون إنهم لا يعرفون
ليس لدينا فكرة عن حجم هذا
هذا هو
الآن ورنين هاتفي
وهو فيرونيك الجار في الطابق السفلي
الذي قال لي إنني لا أعرف ما الذي يحدث
مررت ما يمكنني أن أصعده إليك
أنا في انتظار Véronique Mint وهكذا
خلال هذا الوقت كنا متجمدين أمام
التلفزيون هناك لافتات من خلال التمرير
شاشة إعلان الهجمات
أنا مشلولة أنا أقف بلا حراك
لا أعرف ما الذي يحدث أنا
قطعة من الخشب في ذلك الوقت
[موسيقى]
أنا أقفز وهي التي تلتقط
سألت فتح لي لقد تأذيت
إنه هنا ولكن هذا العام أنا
تعال وفتح لي الأذى
وعلى تحطم وتنص على دانيال
المتواجدون المحبطون
لا أعتقد أن غريزي جدا وهناك
أنا خائف لأن فجأة
إنه اتصال مباشر مع الخارج
لا يزال الوضع هادئًا
مخيفة وكنت خائفة حتى الموت
لم أكن لأعرض نفسي للخطر
إذا لم يتصلوا بي
[موسيقى]
عندما أنزل إلى الطابق السفلي أرى دانيال من
يقف من يمسك بذراعه ونحوه
قدم رجل وجهه لأسفل
ومن هو في حمام دم حقًا
ضحك الدم في كل مكان
[موسيقى]
ومن يقول لدانيال باس بين ياخذ
المصعد يصعد إلى رابع هو
بقيت يانكيز هناك استدر و
أرى فيرونيكا في الطابق السفلي
أيضا
لا أعرف لماذا اتبعتني
لا أتوقع ذلك
[موسيقى]
في الممر بالنسبة لي كنت هناك منذ ذلك الحين
حوالي 15 سنة
ليس معروفا جيدا جيراني لا
أكثر على الفور
إنه معروف حقًا في المساء
الرقص في ظروف مضحكة
[موسيقى]
واجهت مشكلة في الخروج من كريم باتا
لقد تحدثت بالفعل عن أشياء أخرى ولكن
لا باتاكلان
في مكان ما تأثرت به
جسديا ولكن القواعد في الحياة
أصبحت باريس معقدة للعيش
لي
بما في ذلك عامين حتى لو كانت هناك متابعة
نفسي
أعتقد أنني أعود قبل الليل
إنها تقلقني والآخرين في الخارج
الليل
ويتعلق الأمر بالاعتراف بهم كضحايا
تراها كان لها أهميتها بالنسبة لـ
إعادة الإعمار
[موسيقى]
تجاوز في الواقع على الإطلاق هناك
قبل ساعات قليلة من وصولي
الغريب و g2 بسيط
[موسيقى]
كان لي
شهرين ونصف كنت فيها
التصوير في المغرب
في مسلسل تلفزيوني
تعاملت مع الجغرافيا السياسية والتجسس
صناعي
كان لدينا العديد من المنتجات المقلدة
في هذه السلسلة الكثير من الماكياج
المؤثرات الخاصة للمصابين
وانها تبادل لاطلاق النار
الذي أعدني في مكان ما
تاريخ بيادق باتا
[موسيقى]
أين يجب أن ينتهي الأمر بإطلاق النار
مثل 17 نوفمبر لذلك كان علي أن أكون
لا يزال في المغرب في ذلك الوقت وفي
ضع مجلدًا أدخل 13 أ
ساعة قبل حدث باتاكلان
[موسيقى]
وكان مذهلاً للغاية لأن 20
بعد وصولي إلى باتاكلان وأعتقد
بالضبط نفس الشيء وها هو
أكثر وهمية
[موسيقى]
2 شيء من هذا القبيل من قليلا
خاصة حيث ما رأيته أنا
يمكن في مكان ما أ
عقلي يقبلها
اقبل ما كنت اراه
لأنني رأيته من قبل
[موسيقى]
عندما وصلت إلى المنزل هو
كانت الساعة 8:30 مساءً.
كنت على سريري قمت بتوصيله
حتى أنام سأستفيد استفادة كاملة
وصولي غدا أنا متعب
الذهاب إلى النوم
ثم بدأت أسمع أ
ضوضاء في الشارع ما تستطيع
أسمعها بانتظام ولكن أقول لنفسي
إذا كانت نزهة الحفلة هذه غريبة
ليس كالمعتاد تمامًا
نهضت وذهبت إلى المستوى
من المطبخ لمشاهدة ما هو
كان يمر في الشارع هناك بدأت
وقت طويل للصراخ
لكن
[موسيقى]
ما حدث في ذلك الوقت
أننا
نفهم ما يحدث ونحن نفهم
لا شيء في نفس الوقت
وجدت نفسي ملتفًا
في الحماية لأن الجهل
ما كان يحدث بالفعل للذهب
في الخارج وجدت مثل هذا
احمينا وسمعت الصندوق
برونو في الماء وهكذا اتصلت بهم
[موسيقى]
طالما
دخلت في العمل مع
برونو عندما نزلنا
شهر من ذلك الوقت
الشعور بأنني قد حصلت عليه كان أبعد من ذلك
نشعر أن الانعكاس
ركز فقط على شيء واحد لمساعدة هؤلاء
الذين يعانون
عندما نزلت ، دعها تحصل
الدم في كل مكان
[موسيقى]
أتذكر رؤيتها تقول إنها كذلك
لا يمكن أن نرى هذا الرجل لا يستطيع
لا تفعل كل ذلك الدم الذي هو رجل
ليس لديها العديد من الأصوات ، هذا مستحيل
لي
لذلك صعد كلاهما وأنا
وجدت نفسي في الطابق السفلي وحيدًا معها
هناك هذا الرجل الذي كان له وجه
مقابل البلاط والليالي
في كل مكان
كان لديه ساق مطبوعة بالكامل
مع بركة كبيرة من الدم
وأضع يدي على كتفها و
أنا قريب بعض الشيء ، ما زال
لمعرفة ما إذا كانوا يتفاعلون ولأن في
في ذلك الوقت لم يكن لديه على الإطلاق
يتفاعل ثم يتحرك قليلاً
علية
وإذا قلت شيئًا واحدًا فقد كان
خاصة لا أتذكر ما قلته
يبدو لطيفًا حقًا أنك ذاهب
قضاء المساء مع الماء
[موسيقى]
عندما أعود في هذا الوقت أنا
تلتقي Véronique التي صعدت هذا
أنهم يستطيعون في أي رابع قبل
دانيال
[موسيقى]
لذلك عندما يكون لدي قتال ، يكون الأمر كبيرًا
كان ولكن لأنه عن طريق الضوء
التلقائي أقول لنفسي إذا كان مطلق النار الذي
في الشارع سوف يرون
ضوء سوف يأتون وحتى يوم الخميس في
ماثيو لم يبق هناك ، علينا الاختباء
أعتقد أنه مرتبط بالمأوى
لذلك يشكرني
في فرنسا نموذجي
وعلى الفور قال شكرًا لك
لم أفعل شيئا من أجلنا حتى الآن
إنها ملاك أحبك
في ذلك الوقت أعتقد أنه كان كذلك
مرتاح جدا وهكذا نعم ولكن فعلت
بيان في العالم
بالنسبة لي الجزء الأصعب تم إنجازه لكننا
سوف تكون قادرة على تحصن نفسها مغلقة
الباب مقفل لكنني في تلك اللحظة
خوفي ما يدخلون الجزيرة
[موسيقى]
نحاول الاتصال بإدارة الإطفاء
لقد حاولنا الاتصال بـ samu الذي نعاود الاتصال به
مراكز الشرطة يأخذون العنوان
يأخذون إلى الأسماء التي تعرف أ
مرور 14 مايو يوم القديس بيير أميلوت
لا أعرف ما إذا كان بإمكاننا الوصول إليك
اعتصموا
دانيال لا يهدأ للغاية
يأخذ هاتفه ويتصلون به
انظروا أنهم يبحثون عن شاحن
لأنه قال لنفسه أنه ذكر
بطارياتها المشكلة هي أن لدي
هذا الفيديو وأنا لا أستطيع
شحنه
بالنسبة لي عندما رأيته هناك وكان كذلك
صحفي حرب كان لديه
يجب أن تمرر الصورة إلى
زملائي أتذكر أنني
كان يفعل ولكن هذا الرجل لا يستسلم
رواية الإصابة التي تعرض لها
كما أعتقد في حالة صدمة ومع
جرعة من الأدرينالين لم يستطع تناولها
انه في كل مكان يتحدث
قوي جدا جدا
يتذكر وضع الثلاثاء في تونس الصوت الذي
أنا أخرجك
لن تحلم ابني هناك لا يجب عليك
دعهم يرون ذلك
وبالعكس ماثيو الذي أطال
بلا حراك كل شاحب
نحن أقل قلقًا بشأن ظهور
إصابة دانييل من إصابة ماثيو
الذي تقيأ
يبدو الجرح قبيح جدا
اسأل عن الشيء القبيح الجميل
كانت فكرتنا هي جعله يتحدث
يتعلم أنه ينتقل إلى google الذي
الأمريكي أننا سبتمبر أيلول
يقول أنه كان بالفعل في نيويورك
واعتقدت أنه كان يتجول في الحقيقة لدي
عشر حالات محتملة أن الخبز لديهم
هجومين ولا حياته
[موسيقى]
قبل فترة 2 تعادل في حوالي الساعة 11 صباحًا
بدأت أشعر أنك تضعف
ما أضعف ذلك
أنت تدعم نفس الشيء جسديًا و
كلما اعتقدنا أكثر دعنا نقول ضخم نقي و
كان على الأبرياء أن
[موسيقى]
تذكر أنه أحضر لي ديزل لكني أستطيع
لا تموت لا أريد أن أموت عليك أن تموت
دعني أقول لك شيئا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
عندما كنت مستلقيًا على الأرض كان الأمر كذلك
اليائس هو أيضا ثلاثة فقط
قبل أسابيع كنت قد تزوجت
ساره
جمعت كل الاصدقاء كل
أصدقاء العائلة كان هناك ابني
إيلي الذي جاء كان جدا
تتحرك وعلى هدفنا ولكن
كيف سأفعل تزوجت
سأموت
[موسيقى]
كان قلقي الكبير
اسال آدم كقائد لجسده
لأننا نرى أن طولها يبلغ 10 أقدام
ما قلته لنفسي إلا الأوقات
لو كنت أعلم أنه كان فقط إذا كان ليل
كان سيصاب بالذعر لأن syli من جانبه
الحياة ماذا
لذلك أردت أن أمرر إبهامي و
جعله نقطة ضغط تحت
الإبط في الحقيقة وعندما أضع
أتذكر اثنين فقط تحت ذراعه
وشعرت أنني يجب أن أذهب إليها
إصابة في الظهر
وهذا شعور يبقى معي
قوي حقًا ليشعر بهذه الطريقة
لعق الجسد وحرارة
مجال
[موسيقى]
تقول أنك ستموت ولكن ما هذا
ماذا تفعل لفتحه
على عكس ما يقولون تذهب
يتحدى الدولة قراءة وبالإضافة إلى ذلك أنا
قل لي هناك [ __ ] للمباراة حيث كل
زيت الكافور له وهذا هو المكان الذي لديه
لا تخرج
وليل ذلك المساء كان ابني فيه
الشتاء جانب السماء لعبة الدراما لكرة القدم
فرنسا نفسها
نعم ، لقد عاش دائمًا هنا مع
كان من الممكن أن يكون جيدًا جدًا في أصدقائه
مقهى باتاكلان لمشاهدة المباراة
اتصلت بهم على الفور تقول لك
لا تخرج ابقى في المقهى في ديك
إذا كان هذا هو الجهاز الخاص به ، فهناك شيء ما
باتاكلان معقدة للغاية هناك لكنك لا تفعل ذلك
لا تنتقل من مقهى السيرك الذي تقيم فيه
هناك وحتى يتذكره بالكامل
من x
تبعها ونعم أنا مجروح هناك
أنا في انتظار المساعدة للعب أقول ذلك
ويخبرني
أبي لا يغادر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اتجاه باتاكلان على الفور حيث
تسمع طلقات نارية حولها
قاعة حفلات أنطوان فينيو
هي على الفور عواصف
كلاشينكوف واثنان من المعايير
إنقاذ التفجيرات قبل بضع سنوات
دقائق مشابهة لانفجارات
قنابل يدوية حدث ذلك لعدد قليل
عشرات الأمتار من هنا بالتوازي
سمعتهم مرة أخرى مؤخرًا
بعض التفجيرات خاصة في
الشوارع التي خلف باتاكلان
في اتجاه السيرك الشتوي
في وقت من الأوقات كان منتصف الليل فقط
لذلك كانت لا تزال ساعتين
نحاول الاعتراف بذلك
هناك كان هناك تحت سمع العالم أخيرا
كانت المصاريع مغلقة لكنك
لا نرى سمعنا الضوضاء هناك
كانت الجدران تهتز
كان ti لصالح أصوات
كلش الحيل اطلقها من الجميع
الجوانب
هم estel veronique كانوا
مستنسخة ضد جدار الرعب
كان الإرهاب حقا دبي هو
أن هذا الاهتمام وترجمته من
الإرهاب تم ترويعه
[موسيقى]
بالنسبة لي إذا نجوت من مدخل
المبنى لن أموت هناك
نحن نعلم أن الشرطة موجودة
نسمع صافرات الإنذار نسمع
انفجارات ولكن بعد ذلك في مرحلة ما أكثر
لا شئ
لذلك ننتظر قليلاً وفي وقت ما
ابحث عن النافذة وهناك أرى أ
تطويق الشرطة حتى هناك أنا لهم
لذا اتصل لرؤيتي وموراتي
لذلك أنا هنا مثل يد العون
أقولها مرة أخرى ، لدينا جرحى هنا
في اللعبة
دخلوا القاعة
تمكنت من اصطحابه إلى القفص
من السلالم التي نزلت إليها
اترك المصعد لماثيو
أخبار و
هيا بلادي بلا قميص في 101
وكان على عربتي في الثانية
و
أقول له انتظر في المباراة أنا هنا
يؤذي
كان يعتقد أنني إما قناص أو
إرهابي هارب
سقف
لقد فعل ذلك ، إنه مجرد هراء
إنه ذعر كبير مثل مارك
لا أحد يعرف ما الذي يجري
ورجال الشرطة المتخفين ولكن دعوا الماضي و
لحسن الحظ لا أعلم أنه سيكون
الماضي هنا إذا أُصبت بسبب
أن هناك ارتباكًا في المقدمة و
لدغ كبير
أنت تقول هناك كل شيء سيء ولكن مهلا هذا كل شيء
الكمال هناك معجزة
في تلك اللحظة خرجت من الجحيم
العالم وهذا هو لي كان المرحلة
أنا / الثاني بطريقة معينة
حسنًا ، أنا بين يدي
الأطباء هو ببساطة يحدد أن لدي
كل دور الأعصاب وهذا يجعل أ
تأثير الانفجار في ذراعي
ثم عندما كنت أكثر من ذلك بقليل
استيقظت في السراويل القصيرة والبعض
مخدر الارز وماثيو ما هو
أنه أصبح لأنني لم أفعل
منه لم أكن أعرف على الإطلاق ما هو
أصبح
جعلها مصير اثنين
غرف أخيرا كنا بجانبه وهناك نحن
وجدت نفسي ذهبت لأرى لأن
يمكنني المشي
[موسيقى]
فجأة تم اختياره
سوف يسقطون قليلاً ما يتم إخبارهم
التي تركت جيدة جدًا وحصلت علي
أخبر كيف خرج من
الغرفة لأنه كان سيئ الحظ
على ظهره وأصيب
كان يحاول تحديد موعد في فكرته
كان جيدا لا يمكن أن تعمل ولكن
خاصة وأن هناك الكثير من الناس
عليه
على باب الطوارئ عبر صغير
استراحة وهكذا يمكنك الصمود
لذلك وضع أصابعه بشكل واضح
مدمن مخدرات بقوة اليأس
أطلق النار لكن الرجال الذين كانوا
مزق كل عضلاته
إلى الوراء كثيرا أنه تمكن من سحب
اخرج منه
تدحرج على الرصيف المقابل
حتى لا يكون في الحشد وبالتالي هو
انتهى بي الأمر حيث أنا الأسعار
الدائرة كاملة في الحقيقة ليست كذلك
لم تغلق لأنهم بدأوا
شيء آخر يهرب مني تمامًا
هذا هو الجانب الإعلامي
وهناك تحصل على الكثير
في هذا الجنون الإعلامي
لديك كل التلفزيونات كل الصحف
من العالم اجمع
وهناك ترس يبدأ
مكان يصعب إدارته
لقد عملت دائمًا في الظل
وهناك سوف تضيء باستخدام أ
السيرك الاعلامي
قلت لنفسي على أي حال الفيلم
سوف تكون بمثابة وثيقة إثبات و
ثم ربما لا ولكن على أي حال
سيكون هذا أحد الأشياء التي تحدث
شيء يسمع الصحفيين
الشبكات الاجتماعية تشهد على ذلك.
سلاسل هطول الأمطار الكامل هذا
الفورية لا تزال جدا
تنتهك كل المشاعر التآمرية
أخيرًا حدث كل شيء مع الإهانات
حتى يثبت في اليوم التالي أن ملف
كانت الصور أشياء
فهل كان لا بد من بثها أو
ليس هذه الصور هو سؤال إذا كنت
أعتقد ذلك لأننا نخدم
شهادات هذه الحقائق
هناك من الصعب كصورة لكنها ملف
الواقع لا يمكننا إنكاره
إنه الدليل بالصورة وهو كذلك
لقول أن الشهادات هشة
إذا لم أشاهد الصور
كنت سأقول أن الناس سقطوا
واحدًا تلو الآخر بضربات
من النار وخاصة أنه كان هناك
المرأة الحامل شنق fnath الذي
كان مستعدًا للوقوع في الراي بشكل شرعي
يتحدى شهاداتنا
للصور هنا من
تعليق
حتى لو كان مع المشتقات حول هذا
فيديو النخبة والحقائق ولكن
الحقائق عنيدة وهذا ما حدث
يمر
لم أكن ضحية
الى جانب ذلك ، لم أعتبر نفسي
ضحية
لقد خرجت منه بأعجوبة
جيد نوعا ما جيد لذلك كان ذلك أفضل بكثير وبالتالي
أواصل حياتي
عمري 20 عامًا 62 عامًا ، إنها حياتي
هنا لذلك فهو شيء مهم
إنها مليئة بالذكريات الجميلة
ذكريات ذكريات قاسية جدا جدا
صعب
بالنسبة لي كان أيضًا شكل من أشكال
المقاومة متروك للجميع لي
طلب ولكن لم ينتقل إلى تشينون
seilhac إذا انتقلت وهو الشخص الذي
الفوز تياو ما سأهرب مني مكان
وهو لي الذي استثمرته
لقد بنيت هذا يعني أنهم
سيفوز بذلك حتى لو كان لدي عندما
حتى في النادي الذي نأتي إليه
في منزلي
[موسيقى]
وانا كربى الذى زاد
غالبًا ما كنت أفتح ملف
باب منزلي وهناك قاتل
يقتلني وهو يلاحقني بما فيه الكفاية
على طول
كان الأمر صعبًا ولكنه كان بالمناسبة
من كل ما تمكنت من تجميعه فيه
هذا المساء من الجار الذي فكر
أن هناك قاتل قادم
في القاعة ونحن بخير
ولذا كان عليها أن تعمل وكل ذلك و
في الواقع كانت هناك هذه الصدمة
أنه لم يعد موجودًا الآن ولكنه موجود
هل سأقتل
[موسيقى]
لدي كل التكريمات المحروقة
يرمي الإصبع أنني أغني أكثر من ذلك
يؤلم ما يلدغ كما لو كنت
لاذع الآلاف من
الزيت في كل من الأصابع و
عضلات ضامرة
عندما يكون مزعجا قليلا لأنني
أحببت العزف على الجيتار
لا أستطيع الاختيار
[موسيقى]
أوه
تغيرت حياتي في 13 نوفمبر لأنه
حدث أساسي وقع
[موسيقى]
وأنا أغادر هنا ليس بسبب الـ 13
نوفمبر 2013 9 سنوات جزء من بلدي
شقة
في المأساة أو كان هناك على أي حال
السعادة العظيمة
إنها حياة يعيشها الجميع أيضًا
مع تقلباته وما إلى ذلك من الأشياء
جميله اقل جمالا
[موسيقى]
عشت حياتي حتى بلغت العشرين من عمري
المراهقين أخيرًا اثنان يغادران بعد
حياتي البالغة ثم الحياة الثالثة
في 60
تزوجت ولدي طفل
يا له من حظ
بالطبع هناك صدمات.
ولكن شيئا
أنا لا أفعل بشكل سيء للغاية
[موسيقى]
نحن
م
[موسيقى]
أفكر أحيانًا في تلك الرحلة
لقد فعلت ذلك في القدس
[موسيقى]
لقد ضحيت من أجل العرف في
أودعت كلمة لدي
أدخل رقم هاتفي الخلوي
إذا كان الله موجودا فسوف يدعوني رفيق
يوم الخميس
[موسيقى]
بالطبع لم يتصل بي قط
وأحب أن أعتقد أن هذا الرقم 13
نوفمبر 2015 الساعة 10:01 مساءً عند الحب
نحى ضدي في النهاية نشرني
[موسيقى]
م أفضل
الى
في حركته
[موسيقى]